[Music]
hey you guys
time for the tomes of terror show once
again i know last week i kind of did a
sort of
killer kid kind of story
sort of uh confessions which kind of had
a killer kid
aspect to it however this week we are
going
full on murderous child and we are
talking about the 2018
book baby teeth by zoya stage
now this was a book that again uh
you know i saw tons and tons of reviews
of this it seems like the reviews of
this
it's they were very like polarizing like
people either really really loved it
or they really really did not like it
um for various reasons you know that's
fine everyone has their opinions
about it i actually loved this book i'm
just gonna say that
right out front and i didn't really get
i mean i guess i kind of get why people
wouldn't but
i didn't like some of the issues that
people had with the book i didn't really
have
issues with that so your mileage may
vary as
usual but let's kind of talk about this
and like i mentioned
like on a couple of my other reviews i'm
not gonna like outright spoil spoil
anything like i'm not gonna tell you how
it ends or anything like that
but um i am gonna give like a plot
synopsis
and then i might want to go like a
little more in depth into like
what the book is about like what it's
saying and to do that i might have to
spoil some things that you might
prefer not to know about the book so as
usual if you like to come
at books with just no foreknowledge of
what's going to happen in there or as
little foreknowledge as possible then
probably you want to wait until after
you read the book
and then come back and watch this and
then we can
talk about it in the comments if you
would like to so now this is apparently
this is zoya stage's first
novel um i don't know if she's written
anything subsequently
but this seems to be the one that
everyone was uh talking about it came
out in the summer of 2018.
now what this is about is there is a
family uh they live in pittsburgh now
the dad's name
is alex or the jensen family uh the
dad's name is alex he's uh
originally from sweden but he's lived in
the u.s a very long time
and he is kind of like a hipster like a
hot shot
architect like he's kind of like very up
in the avant-garde and the green
movement everything like that
so he's you know that kind of like very
modern dude or whatever
and he has a wife named suzette
who was she's kind of an artist and i
think she also started out as an
interior designer and actually they used
to work together for a time
until they had a kid um at which point
their their lives changed we'll we'll
put it that way
suzette also uh for most of her life
has suffered with crohn's disease uh
which you don't know if it's like an
autoimmune disorder it's you know
uh makes it very difficult to like
digest certain foods and sometimes you
end up having to have like
parts of your small intestine i believe
removed um
you know it's it's not a fun disease and
it's a lot of
people are in a lot of pain all the time
and it's very difficult for them to eat
things
so she has that and she's dealing with
that as well as best as could be
expected because like she's been
suffering from it i believe um from her
teenage years or something like that
so this couple are kind of like they're
they're actually quite
um not wealthy but they're probably
upper middle class um you know they have
a very nice house which
alex kind of designed and um you know
and laid out and that
suzette kind of decorated so they seem
to have this idyllic life they're very
much in love with one another
um he is very supportive of her artistic
ambitions he is very supportive of her
like very helpful you know with her
disease like managing her disease and
things like that
but then they have a kid
now this kid is a little girl and her
name's hannah
they don't talk too much about what the
kid was like when she was growing up the
book is
actually the time that it said in the
modern day the kid is seven years old
they do talk a little bit about like her
being a baby and seemed pretty normal
but then when she was right around three
years old they started to
you know they started to clue into the
fact that maybe something wasn't right
with hannah now one of the main
first things that they noticed was that
hannah
wouldn't talk either she wouldn't talk
or she couldn't talk they couldn't
determine
which of those it was so they started to
get worried because obviously she was
three years old and she wasn't talking
and so it seemed like it was you know
she wasn't meeting all the milestones
they thought it was a little odd
so they basically started taking her to
you know very special scenes there was
something physically wrong with her if
there was some reason why she wasn't
talking if she had some kind of
you know some kind of physical disorder
it seemed like they were mostly trying
to focus on that
but as time went on it became clearer
that it wasn't just the fact that she
was mute
that there also might be something else
the matter with her
it comes to pass that she has been
every time they sent her to a preschool
or later on they tried to take her to
other schools
she always ended up getting kicked out
uh
usually for violent outbursts against
other students
so finally they've kind of exhausted
their
educational possibilities like in the
area and
suzette the mom has had to
basically take on the entire task of
homeschooling hannah
and taking care of her all the time
which means that
she can't have any of her own ambitions
anymore she had to like give up her work
um her crohn's disease has been getting
worse like i said because her medication
is kind of messed up
and so she's kind of dealing with all
that and then she has to deal
with this essentially
demon child in her house so that's kind
of the plot synopsis like i said i want
to go a little bit more
in depth into some [ __ ] that happens in
this so if you don't want to know any
more than that then you know check out
now and then go read it and come back
like i said i'm not going to spoil
anything outright but i do want to kind
of talk about some [ __ ] that happens in
this
book because this book is very
disturbing it's not supernatural there's
nothing supernatural in it
it's basically like i've seen it
compared to
we need to talk about kevin um i've seen
it compared to the bad seed
the uh good son the good son with
macaulay culkin like movie from the 90s
i think it was
so kind of like that so anything where
you have a kid
who is just like a complete [ __ ] and
it's just a terrible terrible person
and how you go about dealing with that
now the way that the book is written is
really interesting it basically goes
back and forth between suzette's point
of view the moms
and hannah's point of view now one
criticism that i saw of this book which
i didn't really find
um you know i didn't find particularly
egregious or it didn't bother me
was that the sections that are written
from hannah's point of view seem
to mature for a seven-year-old
maybe but i didn't really get that
hannah it is established
is not only intensely disturbed
she is also very very intelligent and
very very manipulative
and honestly i thought zoya stage did a
very good job
of kind of finding that balance between
kind of a child-like
mentality like for example one of the
things that
is kind of a running thread throughout
the book is that hannah believes
that she is either channeling or that
there's like the spirit of like an
ancient like a witch that was burned
like during like a french witch that was
during during the
european wish trials is like inside her
and is like helping her out
like helping her to figure out plots of
like destructive [ __ ] she
she's gonna do so she really does
believe that and she believes
wholeheartedly like in curses and and
that they work
you know what i mean she's she takes it
very very seriously so
she still has this very child like
magical thinking kind of thing but then
also she's like a really like
machiavelli machiavellian like
she's just this really manipulative
horrible girl
but she's not like a mastermind like she
does things and they don't go the way
she thinks they're going to go because
her perception
of how her mother and father see her
is erroneous um but she doesn't realize
that you know what i mean so i think
that they
i think that the author did a really
good job of like
conveying that so one thing too that was
really kind of had me on the edge of my
seat during this this was another book
that i read
very very quickly i probably read most
of it in one sitting and then like
finished it up
the next day because it's it's a very
easy read and it's very very
tense it really kind of keeps you it's
not like you know super action-packed or
anything but just like the
[ __ ] up like psychological battle of
wills
like between the mom and the daughter is
just so and it just keeps ramping up and
ramping up and the kid just keeps doing
more and more like [ __ ] up stuff
and it just kind of and you're like it
made me like really nervous like when i
was getting toward the end and i was
just like oh [ __ ] man like what's gonna
happen this is gonna be really really
bad
and it does kind of go in that direction
and another thing too that made it
even more nerve-wracking and more
frustrating
was that alex the husband he seems like
the way he's portrayed in the book he's
just like a very he's a lovely man he's
he's
you know very nice he's very supportive
um he's
clearly loves his wife very much he
clearly loves his daughter very much
but one thing is that hannah the
daughter
is smart enough to essentially
play her mother and father off of each
other because it seems like
when you read the sections that are from
hannah's point of view
in her mind she loves her
dad more than anything else in the world
and she wants
her dad like all to herself so
in her mind like logically to her
she needs to get mommy out of the way by
killing her essentially
she also thinks wholeheartedly believes
that
mommy is also a witch who has cast a
spell
on daddy and is will make daddy not love
her
um so she's constantly trying to like
undermine and manipulate
and she's playing them off one another
so alex the dad
whenever he's around hannah behaves
like an angel she is just like can be
and she's super loving she doesn't talk
but you know she's always like playing
with him she's very happy she's huggy
and everything like that so alex never
sees the demonic side of her i'm using
demonic not in a not in a literal sense
i'm using it to figure a figurative
sense because this kid
is just awful this is an awful awful
child
but he never sees it and even when he
has
other people's testimony of how shitty
her behavior is
like hannah hates her mom and she
basically
will only act out when she's either
alone with
suzette or when she's at school but the
weird thing is is that even though
hannah has been like kicked out of all
of these schools and clearly has
some issues um mainly than not talking
alex kind of refuses to see it which is
frustrating but also really realistic
because that's kind of one thing i think
some reviewers that i saw were like oh
they didn't think this was all that
realistic or
the way that the little girls
essentially
psychopathy um you know sort of
manifested itself was not all that
realistic
or the way that the parents reacted to
it was not realistic
i did not find that to be the case um i
don't
you know i don't have children and after
reading this i'm glad i never had any
and
if you're on the fence about having kids
and you wanted to read this
you will not want them anymore trust me
like after reading that i'm just like
whoo dodged a bullet on that one because
i'm sure man
if you had a kid like this would be
horrifying so the thing about it is that
you know when it's your kid nobody wants
to believe
that their beautiful adorable
little girl who was seven is a
psychopath
you don't want to believe that so i do
feel like
i mean yes they first went like the
physical realm maybe she has a brain
tumor maybe something you know
something like that which is what you
would do because nobody
wants i mean for better for worse i mean
for worse obviously
mental issues still have a lot more
stigma to them than
you know physical disabilities for
example so
obviously parents who sus even if they
suspected
that their child you know was a
sociopath or a psychopath or had
you know those that type of uh disorder
you would really try everything you
could
to not have it be that like to be
something
physical that could be fixed or
something because you know once
once somebody says to you hey your kid
is a psychopath
where do you go from there because they
don't know you know not a lot is known
about it it's like what can we do to fix
this you can't it's not something easy
that you can fix
so i do see how in this book the parents
would be really really reluctant
to put that label on her or
or to believe that that's really what
was going on
now that said obviously suzette the
mother
um is a lot more clued in because not
only
you know she had to deal with all the
schools and stuff that kicked this
little brat out
but she's also with this kid pretty much
all day every day because like i said
she has to homeschool her because no
other schools will take her
and this kid is just awful and she hates
her mom
she wants her mom dead she wants her mom
out of the way and she is constantly
trying to
find ways of doing that or at least i
mean
when it first starts out she kind of is
trying to find
ways to make mommy ugly so that daddy
doesn't love her anymore like cutting
off half of her hair
um and then she tries to like [ __ ] with
her medication
um you know thinking that will make her
die or it'll make her sick or
make her ugly um so she's trying to do
that and then it just keeps like ramping
up and up
so it's very very frustrating that alex
who is like a likable dude he's not an
[ __ ] he's not
mean he's not you know like he clearly
loves his family very much
but he's kind of clueless i mean he's
at work all the time he doesn't see
hannah behaving in any way other than
oh you know she's just special she's
different she's very loving toward him
so then he comes home and you know
suzette's saying
hey she cut off half my hair or hey she
put thumbtacks on the
floor like so i would step on them when
i go to bed like she does stuff like
that
and so alex is almost like not really
believing it or not believing it's as
bad
as suzette is saying that it is
you know even though he's getting input
from the other schools that are like hey
you know she
just barks like a dog or she like hit
this other kid or
you know very early in the story suzette
is out with hannah like at a you know at
a supermarket or something like that
and hannah straight up just like punches
this little baby you know what i mean
like in the head or whatever like
doesn't
really really hurt him but like just
punches this baby and
it just seems it's really frustrating
that suzette is like hey you know your
kid punched a baby and then
the dude's just like oh i'm sure she
didn't mean it or it was an accident or
he's always trying to like come up with
some excuse
as to why hannah acted like that or
maybe suzette's making a big deal out of
nothing so so it's very frustrating but
you can see why because like i said he
doesn't see it so it's not going on
and really it takes almost you know at
least the halfway point of the book
before something happens
that is so egregious that he can't deny
it anymore and then finally
he has a come to jesus moment where he's
just like oh my god something is wrong
with our kid
you know she is putting my wife at risk
so finally he gets on the clue bus and
they
you know start to try to work together
to
figure out what the hell is wrong with
this kid or if something can be done
about her
another aspect i really really liked
about this book
and like i said i'm not a parent but you
know i've i've known a lot of parents
i've been a lot of around a lot of kids
and stuff like that in my life and i've
heard
other people like talk about their
parenting experiences
particularly mothers because i do feel
like
this is kind of sad and maybe it's
getting better than it was but i do feel
like if something is wrong with your kid
the mom's gonna get the blame somehow
you know what i mean especially like
when you see like serial killers and
stuff like
reading about serial killers and they're
always like oh well their mom
was overbearing or their mom was this or
that the other so i do feel like there's
an
aspect of always kind of trying to blame
the mom a little bit
so i like that that's addressed like
to a very large degree in this because
as i said half of the book is
from suzette's point of view so you're
getting like her thoughts her feelings
about this child she clearly loves the
kid
but not only does she have like a
physical disease that she's dealing with
that is chronic and that is very
you know that affects her life like in a
lot of negative ways
but she also had a very troubled
relationship with her own mother
some of that stemming from the crohn's
disease because when suzette was growing
up
she kept complaining about all the pain
she was in and stuff and her mother
never really took it seriously
and so suzette was like a teenager
before it finally got bad enough that
she had to go to the hospital and
they're like hey your intestines are all
[ __ ] up like you need surgery
so she always kind of like resented her
mother for not
really wanting her or not really paying
that much attention or not
you know giving her the love that she
thought she deserved
so now that suzette has her own child
and there is clearly something very
drastically wrong with this child
she can't help but think that is there
anything i could have done different
have
was i did i act like my mother acted
toward me toward her inadvertently and
that's what caused her to be
this way you know is it something that
i've so she
you know blames herself a lot and it's
just really and it's heartbreaking
because i i mean as the book goes on it
kind of
gets to a point where you think that
they don't really
it doesn't really definitively say like
whether hannah
was just born evil like if she's just
like a horrible horrible child if she
can be helped
or if it was something that the mom did
because there are a couple of
things that happen in the book where
like for example i'll probably i'll give
an example like
she has built this little she has this
favorite book that she reads um
hannah does her daddy always reads it to
her and it's about this little
creature called an under slumber bumble
beast
yeah so it's this little creature from
what i could determine
that is like made of like all these
little spare parts and then it like
comes to life
so her dad gives her like a potato and
tells her you can make your own
you know what i mean so she makes it
with all these pencils and stuff and
like sticks
under her bed but because suzette didn't
know
about that and didn't know what the
story was she
sees this thing like under her
daughter's bed and she thinks that it's
a voodoo doll because of the way that
one of the eyes is drawn and then like
one of this
like a teacher at this this one school
that they try to put hand in like he had
something wrong with his eye
so she was almost like believing she's
like holy [ __ ] like maybe
maybe this is a voodoo doll and maybe
this [ __ ] really works like that's kind
of at the stage that she's at like she
knows there's no possession she knows
there's nothing like that
but the fact that she entertained that
possibility for a second
just goes to show like how [ __ ] over
it
over it she is like dealing with this
dealing with this [ __ ] demon's bond
child that she has
so i really like too that they added
that aspect
of suzette constantly questioning
herself like maybe
maybe something i did caused her to be
this way maybe
me reacting to her in a particular way
is making her like this
and for the first half of the book she's
very very isolated because like i said
alex her husband doesn't ever see the
daughter
behaving in this particular manner
because the kid is smart enough to like
manipulate
him and like like i said work them
against each other so it's almost like
this weird sick competition
like between the mom and the daughter
without suzette
really fully grasping that it's a
competition maybe like i don't know if
she necessarily
sees it that way um she does kind of
i think maybe she does harbor some
resentment toward the kid for
you know it used to be like when it was
just her and her husband
um you know and they were working
together and she got a lot more
you know she did her artistic stuff and
she was a lot happier more you know
now she's kind of like tied down at home
all the time like with this
kid who you know clearly hates her so
there is some resentment there but it's
understandable resentment
so but i really like the way it kind of
goes into
like this thorny issue of
you know the mom constantly questioning
her decisions constantly blaming herself
am i making too big a deal about this is
alex right about it is
you know should i try to be nicer should
i try to communicate with her in a way
that
you know she would understand maybe i'm
doing something wrong
so i really do like that that that they
go a lot into that
because it leaves it this kind of
ambiguous you don't really know
you know whether there is anything that
could have been done differently
that would have made this horrible child
turn out
any better you know what i mean so
that said like i said now if you're
really into
evil kid stuff i mentioned before uh we
need to talk about
kevin which was actually about kind of
an older kid i think it was like a
psychopath he was a school shooter i
believe
the good sun anything like that
particularly the bad seed this reminded
me a lot of that
so if you really really like evil kid
books you will probably really dig this
this is not like i said it's not
there's nothing supernatural about it
there's nothing
it's very very grounded and very
realistic
you know to a degree although obviously
it might be a little bit exaggerated
because some of the
[ __ ] that this little kid comes up with
is just um i didn't really think it was
that unbelievable that like a
seven-year-old kid like a really bright
one
would come up with some of this [ __ ]
because she had like logic behind what
she was doing and to me it seemed very
much like seven-year-old kid logic
other people's mileage may vary if you
have a seven-year-old kid and it seemed
like unrealistic to you i'm not
saying that that's not the case i'm just
saying from my point of view
having been around you know children
that age a lot because my parents used
to run a daycare my mom ready to take
care of the house and then they ran
like a regular daycare with like you
know dozens and dozens of kids
being around some kids i would not put
it past some seven-year-olds to totally
like
pull this kind of [ __ ] and like no so
i'm just saying i did
i didn't find it unrealistic in the
slightest but some of the [ __ ] that she
does
is like really really [ __ ] up and
maybe if you have a kid
it this might kind of bother you like
because some of the [ __ ] that
suzette thinks about the kid but coming
from my point of view
as an adult and imagining myself in
those
shoes of like having this child and you
had all these
you know hopes and dreams about how this
little girl was going to turn out and
she looks adorable and everything and
then she just turns out to be
essentially a monster how would you feel
about that it's a you know what i mean
would you contemplate you know even
killing the kid which she kind of does
at some point but she doesn't really go
that far
but you can understand why somebody
would think that
because what the [ __ ] else like some of
the [ __ ] that this kid does is just like
super [ __ ] up and you just kind of
at some point you're gonna have to like
throw up your hands and be like you know
i don't know what to do
uh with this child because it's just
you know what i mean so it basically i
think it's
marketed as a psychological thriller
which i guess it sort of is
but it definitely does shade into
psychological horror i mean some of the
[ __ ] that happens in this is like pretty
messed up
um so it's kind of occupies the same
space i guess as
confessions which i was talking about
last week which is kind of
not like overtly like gory horror or
anything like that but it's like really
creepy
like psychological horror and
kind of getting into the mind of a
family like a really dysfunctional
family that seems like really perfect on
the surface
but then kind of getting into the heads
of the mom and the kid
and this kind of like battle of wills
between them
i kind of liked a lot of people i i
noticed like um
some of the reviews too like i said this
seemed like one that was either like
five stars or one star like some people
really seem to hate it
i like i said the the main criticism i
saw was oh it was unrealistic like a
seven-year-old kid couldn't come up with
some of that [ __ ] which
i disagree but like i said i don't you
know i don't know and
a lot of people didn't like the ending
because they thought it wasn't
you know i don't want to give too much
away but they thought that it was too
ambiguous or
it didn't go the way they thought it was
going to go or they thought that it was
going to be like a bigger splashy ending
or something like that but that really
didn't bother me at all
i actually really liked how it ended i
like that it kind of i don't
know if i'd call it like open an
open-ended
end it was kind of like that but i kind
of like that because like i said it was
more realistic
because you know when you're approaching
a
kind of a sensitive subject matter like
this from that point of view it's like
there's really only unless you're
introducing supernatural elements which
this doesn't have
you know there's only a couple ways that
it can go and
also when you're dealing with a kid that
has this
you know clearly very severe mental
illness there's really not a lot because
it's such a nebulous
you know topic you don't really know how
it's gonna go you don't know
i mean is this kid ever gonna be able to
get better i mean is she gonna like grow
up normal or is she just always gonna be
this way is there anything we can do
about it
and so like i said there's you don't
know that so i like that the book kind
of
went with that idea so as i said
if you're into evil kid stuff i really
like evil kid movies and evil kid books
and stuff like that
and this kid is pretty [ __ ] evil um
so and like i said if you
you need some like birth control or
something like some some
cheap birth control this buckle to it
it's like seriously if you've if you're
thought well maybe maybe someday i'd
like to have a kid yeah read this and be
like okay yeah no [ __ ] that
but yeah so it's definitely a really
good book and i will be uh looking out
for more stuff from uh
zoya stage as well because this is uh
pretty awesome
like for a first novel and uh that'll do
it for tomes of terror this week and
i'll see you on the next one
bye